[Music]
6:00 in the morning in Seattle I'm sorry
he was into me from the second I got it
why did she were my daughter away from
it moving was Sam's idea fantastic last
night he would have said no so I didn't
call me when you get to the airport we
have unconfirmed reports of a large
seismic event off the California coast
with reports of power outages across the
United States why did you go back I
didn't know where else to go
have you talked to Sam we got
disconnected what's the last thing she
said she sounded scary
that's not where we know him we have no
idea what's happening yeah we got 22 is
doing flybys she's alone 2,000 miles
away so I only have one question for you
are down the government is silent we
don't know who or what is causing this
there's a lot to be afraid about a lot
of real danger keep adding gun assuming
that you've never fired a firearm
I've seen war game simulations events
just like this you're designed to have
raise rational behavior with what
appears to be a singular incident you
ever seen clouds like that before
you just drive about us
[Music]
I can't stay like this forever
do you really think that
[Music]
[Music]
you